do you know the gender the baby yet  we've never told anyone so i'm gonna you  haven't told  you no i saved it for you kelly i love  my gosh  are you excited what you thought you  were pregnant with um  no because i did all those they're so  excited i did all those like  look online of like how big how fast the  heart beat where do your hips go and i  was like oh it must be this i was wrong  okay they're gonna tell you because they  never get to tell anyone  [Applause]  oh my god that this is the first time  you're telling people  you were so sweaty oh my gosh it's so  exciting have you already bought stuff  no what because it's like i don't know  i'm  oh i don't i can't say how long i am i  don't know i'm just over halfway  yeah and um  and then people want to buy me stuff and  i'm like well i'm gonna have two cribs  like what do i do  help me